you know jigging walking on the red
carpet with his mom and dad today and
his that made headlines he would virus
right away so here I was five dad ashtag
hot dad he's not embarrassed how does
that how does that make you feel that
you actually went viral yeah it came out
on the Golden Globes and I was sitting
in the Golden Globes and my phone
started going crazy and I checked it on
commercial break and it was family
friends and a lot of co-workers from
work giving me a hard time but it's all
in fun somebody's gonna call you it's
not a bad thing to be called it's not a
bad thing to be called yeah surprise I
mean that's why I married him right aha
hashtag hot mom - what's it like
watching your son give such a great
performance and now be kind of the belle
of the ball at the award season at Halle
you know when it's surreal when we were
taping it we were watching it we were
obviously there and as parents we were
like this is really good but then we got
to sit back and fit is it just because
we have our parent goggles on and
everything our son does is great so it's
great to see all this and know that
everyone else kind of agrees with us
that he did a great job
we all deal with more than press we're
always proud of him but now it's just so
happy for all these opportunities and to
see him enjoying all this it just there
isn't words I can't talk about I'll cry